a sex scandal that has morphed into
criminal charges for former president
Donald Trump has Nevada's fingerprints
all over it Trump's alleged affair with
adult film star Stormy Daniels
reportedly began 17 years ago at a Lake
Tahoe golf tournament eight new
investigators Chief reporter George
Knapp contained exclusive details about
where he started right here
of a sexual nature
adult film star Stormy Daniels was 27
when she met then 60 year old Donald
Trump at a celebrity golf tournament at
Lake Tahoe in 2006 according to Daniels
she and Trump had a brief sexual tryst
in Trump's hotel room she met him two
more times once in New York and again in
Beverly Hills the fleeing fizzled she
claims after Trump informed her that she
would not be appearing on his hit TV
show The Apprentice rumors about the
affair percolated to the surface
multiple times over the ensuing years
Daniels whose real name is Stephanie
Clifford was living at this home in
North Las Vegas in 2011 when a magazine
publisher interviewed her and planned to
reveal the sorted details in order to
bolster Daniel's claim the publisher
asked her to undergo a polygraph Las
Vegas polygraph examiner Ron slay who's
conducted more than 27 thousand lie
detector tests some involving high
profile figures was given the job
Daniels met slay at his office on
Maryland Parkway in May 2 2011 slay made
a video recording of the nearly
four-hour exam although only a single
frame from that video has been made
public 8 news now was able to view the
entire video back in 2018. the publisher
had submitted 17 questions for Daniels
to answer slay whittled that down to
three Central issues one did you have
intercourse with Donald Trump Daniels
yes two did you have unprotected sex
with Donald Trump Daniels yes three did
Trump say he would get you on The
Apprentice Daniels yes in a confidential
report we obtained slay wrote the
probability of deception was less than
one percent although he listed the third
question as inconclusive but the
publisher did not release the story
Trump's attorney Michael Cohen had
threatened to sue both the magazine and
Daniels a guy walked up on me years
later Daniels told 60 Minutes that after
taking the polygraph she was threatened
by an unknown man as she parked her car
outside a Las Vegas Health Club Daniel
spent a lot of time in Las Vegas she not
only lived here for a year but was a red
carpet fixture at the annual adult video
Expo and has made special appearances at
local adult clubs they're mathematically
out they ought to quit during the 2016
presidential campaign As Trump won
primary after primary she says her fears
grew more pronounced near the end of the
2016 campaign multiple media Outlets
were working on a potential story about
her trust with Trump the story was
quashed after fixer Michael Cohen paid a
hundred thirty thousand dollars for the
rights as for the video of the polygraph
exam those rights were purchased by
Daniel's former attorney Michael
avenatti who is currently serving a
14-year prison term Cohen likewise went
to federal prison on charges related to
the payment of hush money to vote
Daniels and another woman as president
Trump was questioned aboard air force
one about the payments to Daniels he
deferred to Cohen both Cohen and Daniels
have reportedly spoken with New York
prosecutors in recent months as criminal
charges against Trump were being crafted
the story that started out as a rumor 17
years ago in Nevada has now become a
front burner issue in presidential
politics George Knapp 8 News Now
CBS is reporting that the grand jury
voted to indict former president Trump
in the hush money case however the exact
charges as we mentioned have not yet
been revealed